wir haben jetzt über zwei jahre corona
maßnahmen hinter uns es geht um die
frage gehen wir in den herbst und viele
viele fragen sind noch offen nämlich
erstens über welche zahlen reden wir
warum versperrt man sich auf landes aber
letztens auf der bundesebene vor einer
evaluation evaluierung der zahlen mit
was gehen wir jetzt in den herbst und
natürlich nicht zuletzt die frage
bleibt jetzt auch dabei politik der
spaltung ist immer noch genannt
impfkampagne wird die wieder
hochgefahren wird auch über die frage
risiken und nebenwirkungen der impfung
und so weiter gesprochen das ist das
thema was mir als anwalt natürlich am
herzen liegt weil ich auch schlichtweg
sagen das muss dringend juristisch
aufgearbeitet werden weil es vielleicht
auch ein beitrag sein kann zur
allgemeinen befriedung ich stellen sie
sich die juristische aufarbeitung vor
die stelle ich mir gar nicht vor die ist
schon ganz praktisch weil wir haben
tatsächlich ja während der gesamten zeit
sehr viele klagen geführt wir haben an
vielen verwaltungsgerichten klagen
geführt und wir sind jetzt in der phase
dass diese ganzen einstweiligen
verfahren die laufen jetzt in der
hauptsache ich als anwalt bin dazu
ausgebildeten sachverhalt zu ermitteln
und gerade bei corona kann ich keinen
sachverhalten in dem sinne ermitteln
weil mir die stellen die den sachverhalt
ermitteln könnten nämlich die
institutionen wie das
robert-koch-institut und andere den
sachverhalt nicht erklären und das führt
übrigens auch dazu dass auch viele leute
sich einen eigenen sachverhalt schaffen
und dann sagt aber du bist deutschland
erklärt doch den leuten mal und und
nicht und dieses zahlen gewöhnt was dann
sozusagen darüber hängt das ist
natürlich nicht verständlich weil man es
auch nicht draußen sieht sozusagen und
deswegen muss es dahin wo es geklärt
werden kann das wird nicht auf straßen
geklärt das wird nicht in die debatten
den talkshows geklärt sondern am ende
des tages müssen wir den rechtsstaat
stärken dass er sowas auch auf und
nachbereitet und wir sagen können
passiert uns das noch mal laufen wir
wieder wild wings in solche krise hinein
wie sehen sie das denn heparin als
unternehmer wenn sie zurückblicken auf
dem coconut pandemie ja mich mich
interessiert ja immer der mensch
dahinter tatsächlich als selbständiger
das brauche ich in der runde kam zu
erzählen war es sehr sehr schwierig ich
denke die orientierungslosigkeit war er
maßgebend für die ganze situation
ich denke aber auch die
informationsfülle die nicht aufbereitet
wurde passt ganz gut dazu
aufklärung wäre viel besser gewesen
finde ich ich weiß es war die erste
pandemie und es war für jeden neu aber
mich hat dieser wissenschaftliche ansatz
der hat mir gefehlt den wir in der
universität gelernt haben auch sie mit
einem doktortitel karl aut habe für mich
ist er schon lange der minister der
ausgrenzung und er hat wieder einmal
bewiesen dass er es bleiben will
erinnern wir uns einmal zurück an eine
zeit die für viele ganz schlimm war
zweig im winter diese fürchterliche
spaltung die wir erlebt haben wir haben
menschen in gruppen einsortiert du bist
geimpft du bist nicht geimpft du bist
solidarisch weil du bist bist du bist
nicht solidarisch weil du nicht geimpft
ist die zeit bei fürchterlich und sie
war falsch wir haben ja auch schon
gestern der runde gehabt die gesagt
haben ich habe nur gedacht ich habe
nachgedacht und mir tut es auch leid was
letzten winter passiert ist aber einer
der sie das nicht so das ist unser
gesundheitsminister karl lauterbach der
unterscheidet immer noch auch jetzt
zwischen den guten und den bösen die
sich gegen die impfung entschieden haben
und hat sich erst gestern über
demonstranten echauffiert und ich möchte
ihnen das gerne hier einmal zeigen
runde stehen und haben dazu keine kölner
gelassen
recht
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das
stellen haben
richtig
zu missbrauchen den gearbeitet haben
dieses wissen der tod möglich belastet
sind
kommt herr lauterbach und sagt na ja es
gibt nicht nur die kämpfen ungeimpften
es gibt auch die rechtmäßig
demonstrierenden und die unrechtmäßig
demonstrieren er maßt sich an er macht
sich kompetenz an dir nicht hat das ist
leiter der rote faden und ich muss sagen
gäbe es nicht noch schwächere wäre er
schon weg aus dem kabinett verriet wenn
sie das sehen denken sie gut dass ich
deutschland verlassen habe gesehen hat
wusste ich
habe
natürlich möchte ich wissen was in
deutschland los ist und dann werden laut
aber auch sie das ist
gänsehaut sagt sieht auch nicht gesund
aus der mann gibt auch nicht viel
gesundes von sich ich halte von ihm
wirklich nichts vom fehler und ich denke
da sollte man mal was macht man muss
wirklich sagen ich habe noch nie ein so
gespaltenes land erlebt wie in den
letzten zwei jahren und die gespräche am
familientisch oder in freundeskreisen
drehten sich immer um die frage bist du
schon geimpft oder bist du es nicht und
sie haben sich am ende in diese beiden
richtungen gespalten das ist furchtbar
für ältere menschen zerbrachen
freundeskreise
senioren haben sich nicht mehr getraut
ihre kinder oder enkelkinder zu sehen
was ist das für ein zustand man konnte
nicht mehr im beisein seiner angehörigen
dieses leben diese welt verlassen das
ist das ist ich finde dafür keine worte
darf sich nie wieder und dafür mein
thema ist ja auch eine der schlimmsten
long beach phänomene und nicht nur herr
professor doktor karl lauterbach ist
also ein long beach phänomen nicht nur
er bläst als wir die backen auf und
schlägt auf die panik trompete und bläst
also die tuba der angst nein es gibt
leider gottes auch ein team lauterbach
besonders bei den gesundheitsministern
wie sie heute getagt haben er steht
nicht allein auf weiter flur genauso
starke panische angst getriebenen
machtbewusste töne stimmen
beispielsweise die gesundheitsminister
von baden württemberg und von bayern an
einen grünen politiker und ein csu
politiker es gibt neue vorschläge auf
dem tisch von bayern von baden
württemberg von hessen vielleicht auch
von thüringen zum einen der
instrumentenkasten soll nachgeschärft
werden ich denke mein al capone der
macht ja den koffer auf land denkt dass
er ein stelle drin und es kommt das
maschinengewehr zum vorschein also der
instrumentenkasten ist er ein folter
kasten zweig sind wieder drin sein 3g
masken tragepflicht
abstandsgebot
versammlungsverbote etc das wenn man
alles schaffen und zwar schon am ersten
siebter also am gleichen tag an dem die
evolution erst vorliegen will das heißt
man arbeitet schon vor ohne die
evaluation zu kennen und sogar der alte
gassenhauer kommt aus der geisterbahn
zurück herr mit der impfpflicht ab 60 am
gleichen tag also an dem österreich die
allgemeine impfpflicht abgeschafft
erklären uns einige gesundheitsminister
im schönen sachsen anhalt für müsse noch
mal nachdenken über die gesundheits
pflichtpartie über die impfpflicht ab 60
die krachend gescheitert ist herwig hat
heute einen schönen satz gesagt der hat
ja gesagt wir kommen später auch auf ihn
zu sprechen es sei ja ganz ganz schlimm
dass er nun die kohleverstromung wieder
aufnehmen müsse es ging allerdings nicht
anders und er sagte das sei elend aber
notwendig für die deutsche corona
politik geht nur die hälfte dieser
aussage sie ist elend aber komplett
unnötig verschenkt die union hat ja als
die korona politik zurückblickend
betrachtet auch einiges mitgemacht oder
auch selbst gemacht was man sagen haben
als wasser regierungspartei hat sich der
kurs denn jetzt innerhalb der partei
auch verändert wissen sie ich sehe da
ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so einen großen
unterschied zwischen den parteien weil
es ist er unterschied zwischen menschen
sie haben in allen parteien die fraktion
angst oder vorsicht wenn sie so nennen
wollen und sie haben auch in allen
parteien leute die das komplett ablehnen
oder sich irgendein irgendeiner weise
damit schwer tun weil es ist eine ganz
menschliche eine ganz persönliche frage
um die es geht und deswegen kann ich da
sozusagen kein und kein unterschied
zwischen die leiste reihen der union was
die vernunft überwiegt bei der union das
muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen haben wir
sind ja damals mit unserem antrag
eingegangen ein impf register
einzuführen ich habe im übrigen auch
damals diesen abgelehnt weil ich habe
mich dem kubicki antrag angeschlossen
für mich war nichts dergleichen mehr
akzeptabel
richtungs bezogen fiel darauf keine
laufen auch gegen auf keinen fall weil
ich habe heute auch die pflegerinnen und
pfleger bei mir im büro zu sitzen die
ungeimpft sind und in gefahr laufen
jetzt ihren job zu verlieren und das
halte ich hochgradig unverantwortlich
weil wir nicht den beleg dafür haben
dass eine ungeimpfte pflegekraft für
andere eine größere gefahr sein ich habe
mir die mühe gemacht mal ein bisschen
nachricht wurde aufzulisten warum der
deutsche sich seit 500 jahren so
ziemlich alles gefallen lässt
und wer sich mal etwas nicht gefallen
lässt dann nach oben durch notiert nach
wie vor 1914 die tour a 92 33 und 39
aber ich glaube es gibt kaum ein land
kaum eine nation darf man ja heute schon
fast nicht mehr sagen dass ich so viel
gefordert bis zum heutigen tag ja ich
kann sich die bevölkerung an
scharf geduldig erträgt sie die
steigerung der energiepreise schaafs
geduldig erträgt sie die 7,9 prozent
wahrscheinlich sind die schon schön
gerechnet inflationsrate schaafs
geduldig erträgt der deutsche michel wie
er
meine tägliche
gehirnwäsche gib mir heute bei den
öffentlich-rechtlichen ich glaube das
darf man der runde ja sagen gibt da
keinen gibt da keine tatort der nicht
politisch korrekt durchgestylt ist und
so weiter und so weiter mehr er lässt
sich sagen du hast antifaschistisch zu
sein du hast die kolonialistisch zu sein
das antirassistisch zu sein und so
weiter und so weiter mehr und der
deutsche
erträgt es duldet es bei ihnen ist das
ja interessant im grunde weise sie sind
ja nicht nur autor sondern sie sind ja
auch im grunde chef pädagoge und treten
ja bereits der auf und sieht lange als
eine solche aufgetreten wie zusammen ja
gab es 20 jahre das hilft es 30 jahre
chef des lehrerverbandes und ich mir
angucke was alles in unseren schulen
läuft und schief gelaufen ist dann frage
ich mich wo waren sie als es darum ging
wer tatsächlich gerechtigkeit in schulen
einzuführen wo waren sie als es darum
ging mehr ganztagsschulen einzuführen wo
waren sie als es darum gegen mehr
betreuung an den schulen einzuführen
also 30 jahre offenbar nicht so viel
gemacht und jetzt kluge worte warten da
frage ich mich was ist denn da schief
gelaufen und mein thema heute abend was
nicht bewegt ist der gender wahnsinn
beim öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunk ich
sage schluss mit der erziehung also was
ist eigentlich passiert ich saß heute
morgen bei einem tee vor meinem handy
wenn durch instrumente scrollt und
plötzlich habe ich gedacht was ist das
ich habe also angeschaut um zu sehen
dass jetzt sie auch eingeblendet drei
arten wie freund schauen das richtig
schöner ihnen schaffen enden können ja
das ist bei mädels haben erschien das
ist ein kanal von funk und funk ist es
konnte ein netzwerk von ard und zdf für
junge menschen wenn ich dass sie ihre
freundinnen schaffen dann habe ich mich
erst mal gefragt mein bester folgen die
ich erst ein mann ich bin eine frau
sollte ich jetzt unsere freundschaft
eine freundin schafft nennen oder eine
freundschaft nennen damit keines von
unserem geschlechtern zu kurz kommt
schluss mit der sendereihe schluss mit
der freundinnen schafft denn das ist
sexistisch
frau burka wie sehen sie das sind auch
eine frau wenn wir jetzt befreundet
wären hätten wir eine freund innen
schafft oder dürfte ich noch
freundschaft sagen was würden sie
bevorzugen habe persönlich finde ich
dieses thema so ein bisschen anstrengen
also ich meine man muss nicht irgendwie
die wörter so komplex kompliziert weil
ich wird tatsächlich bevorzugen wenn wir
uns einfach eine freundschaft ist
einfach immer sie tatsächlich und ich
finde es beginnt auch schon dieses ganze
thema allein schon bei der beziehung
also ich glaub wenn irgend wie die
mütter haben beziehungsweise eltern
möglich sich darum kümmern würden was
die kinder so erzogen werden dass sie
nicht diese das ist nicht so ausartet
dass auch die kinder sorgen dass sie
mehr darauf achten auch dass die frau
zum beispiel mehr wie soll ich sagen
dass ich mir das mehr respekt auch über
den herrscht dann würden wir glaube ich
auch bei dem thema gar nicht so
überlegen okay wie könnte man das so ein
bisschen vorsichtiger angehen die themen
und dem begriff so mende und sonstige
ist also ich glaube das artet auch ein
bisschen außerirdisch gesagt herr plus
wie sehen sie das lassen sie das zu
ändern auch sein oder wollen sie uns
damit anfangen damit die union jung und
cool web und vielleicht sexy nein ich
lehne auch die gender sprache ab will
aber vielleicht noch mal eine sache
unterscheiden also wer privat so reden
möchte und sagen möchte zuschauer innen
oder zu hörende oder anwohnern weinen
oder fahrende oder freundinnen schafft
der soll das bei der grillparty tun ich
mache das nicht und ich kenne auch in
meinem freundeskreis niemanden der das
macht und glaube auch dass eine mehrheit
im land einfach normal deutsch spricht
aber der entscheidende punkt finde ich
ist doch dass diese gender sprache und
die ganze ideologie die dahinter steckt
immer stärker in öffentliche
einrichtungen einzieht in universitäten
in schulen die schüler oder schülerinnen
und schüler lernen ja häufig gar nicht
mehr richtig die deutsche grammatik
sondern kriegen die gender sprache
beigebracht die ja grammatisch falsch
ist und da finde ich hört der spaß dann
auf das darf die politik nicht zu lassen
und deswegen brauchen wir einen gender
verbot in schulen in universitäten in
öffentlichen einrichtungen da sollte die
deutsche grammatik herrschen und die
deutsche grammatik gelebt werden ich
meine man kommt sich ja wirklich vor ein
bisschen wie ein absurdes daran dass man
überhaupt so etwas fordern muss und wer
das im privat anders halten will der
soll das tun aber
am ende mit dem punkt auch noch mal
machen wir sagen immer auch völlig
zurecht wenn wir über integration
sprechen
die sprache ist der schlüssel und
sprache so einfach und verständlich sein
wir haben ja nicht nur eine gender
sprache sondern es gibt ja die mit
doppelpunkt es gibt die mit gender
sternchen nicht es gibt die mit
irgendwie das alles in ein partizip
umgewandelt wird na also eben zu hörende
oder studierende oder an wohnende oder
sparende oder mieten de oder stadt
habe ich neulich seiner bauen.de also es
wird da immer abstruser und
das finde ich kann nicht sein da
brauchen wir auch wenn wir gerade im
schlaf sprache in öffentlichen räumen
reden in staatlichen einrichtungen
brauchen wir verständlichkeit brauchen
wir einfachheit und brauchen wir die
deutsche grammatik aber erst mal mache
ich jetzt mein aufreger entspreche über
eine andere junge damen und die heißt
emilia fester sie ist
bundestagsabgeordnete der grünen und hat
auf instagram bürger eingeladen jetzt
werden sie denken das ist doch nett was
soll daran schlimm sein eigentlich ist
es auch eine wirklich schöne idee wenn
frau fester nicht bürger aus grenzen
würde sie schreibt auf instagram ihr
habt vielleicht schon in meinem posting
gesehen von gestern ich würde euch gerne
mit zu einer berlinfahrt nehmen wenn ihr
eine junge frau oder inter trans nicht
binäre person aus hamburg seit lade ich
euch herzlich ein hier sieht man es
eingeblendet alle jungen find hast die
nicht in hamburg wohnen können auch
kommen müssten aber reisen und sich der
gruppe anschließen falls sie jetzt nicht
wissen was hinter bedeutet dass es kein
problem ich muss es auch google winter
sind frauen sowie intern nicht binäre
und trans personen sowie menschen die
sich ohne geschlechtsidentität erleben
man stelle sich jetzt einmal vor ein
mann ein bundestagsabgeordneter würde zu
einer reise nur für männer und alte
frauen ausrufen also ehrlich gesagt das
wäre zu recht ein riesen desaster und
ich finde ausgrenzung sollte keine
einbahnstraße sein was fällt frau fester
eigentlich ein nur menschen einzuladen
die keine männer und keine älteren
frauen sind die viren wärs dir auch ein
gefallen das zu tun du bist ja auch eine
junge frau findest du auch männer sollte
man nicht einladen wie herr schäfer zu
der reise also ich kann dir sagen ich
muss darüber eigentlich nur schmunzeln
weil wir reden über gender pay gap über
über gleichberechtigung und handeln dann
eigentlich genau im gegenteil genau so
wie bei den ganzen female am powerman
events wo männer ganz klar ausgegrenzt
werden das ist totaler schwachsinn aus
meiner sicht deswegen kann ich das
überhaupt nicht nachvollziehen ich bin
ja mal gespannt wie die abstimmt wenn
ich darum gehen die frauen hat hamann
und die diskriminierungs beauftragten zu
wählen müsste sie ja eigentlich dagegen
entscheiden grundsätzlich finde ich das
ja gut junge frauen zu stärken und ich
glaube das ist auch super wichtig aber
warum nicht auch junge männer warum
müssen die dann ausgeschlossen werden
das verstehe ich nicht also müssen die
eigentlich jung und alt gegen das ist ja
also ich glaube das ist glaube ich der
punkt wahrscheinlich wollten sie das gar
nicht so sagen aber am ende soll doch
jeder die möglichkeit haben mit fand ich
finde ist auch in ordnung wenn man sagt
ich gehe auf reisen und suche mir die
person aus als freiheitsliebender mensch
würde ich sagen das muss jedem erlaubt
sein zu sagen ich nehme nur ich die
ausreise und nur diese runde mit und
niemand anderem dann ist das doch in
ordnung